[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os preguntara por un país en el que
más del 80% de sus habitantes viven en
viviendas construidas por el estado
seguro que muchos pensaréis en alguna
república socialista o tal vez en algún
país de la antigua órbita soviética
verdad pero y si os digo que esta cifra
corresponde a uno de los países con la
economía más libre y más desregulada del
mundo tal vez al país más capitalista de
todos sorprendidos amigos singapur es
todo un caso aparte una excepción en
cuanto al modelo de vivienda
esta ciudad estado del sudeste asiático
famosa por sus altos rascacielos de
oficinas o su arquitectura imposible y
por ser uno de los mayores centros
financieros del mundo ha desarrollado un
sistema de vivienda de promoción pública
único en el mundo
pero puede que alguno de vosotros esté
pensando pero alberto si en visual
político ya nos contaste y es que viene
también hay un sistema de vivienda
pública enorme pues si nos falta razón
sin embargo hablamos de dos modelos muy
pero que muy diferentes completamente
distintos
[Música]
de hecho la gran diferencia entre el
modelo de viena del que nos habló
fonseca hace muy poco tiempo aquí en
visual político y el de singapur se
puede ver sobre todo en el porcentaje de
propietarios
mientras que el modelo vienés está
orientado al alquiler las tres cuartas
partes de la población viven de alquiler
en viviendas propiedad del ayuntamiento
que el modelo de singapur es justo todo
lo contrario
más del 90% de los ciudadanos de
singapur son propietarios el 80%
propietarios de viviendas promovidas
construidas y adjudicadas por el estado
[Música]
si lo habéis escuchado bien vivienda de
promoción pública orientada a la
propiedad una propiedad con matices todo
hay que decirlo pero de todo esto
hablaremos más tarde antes tenemos que
hacernos algunas preguntas porque
singapur
aparentemente rechaza el modelo de libre
mercado para el sector inmobiliario cómo
diantres se puede desarrollar un sistema
de vivienda pública orientado a la
propiedad como ha afectado este modelo a
los desarrollos inmobiliarios privados
es acaso replicable el modelo de
singapur a otros países pues bien hoy
respondemos a todas estas preguntas
atentos
[Música]
singapur poco suelo y mucha población
queridos amigos queridas amigas de
visual política lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es ponernos en contexto fijaos
un momento en este mapa
singapur es una ciudad-estado de poco
más de 700 kilómetros cuadrados pero con
más de 5 millones y medio de habitantes
esto ha obligado a que más del 70 por
ciento del terreno lo que son las zonas
rojas en el mapa ya esté construido el
30% restante una parte considerable son
zonas protegidas o terrenos donde
simplemente no se puede construir
[Música]
vamos que la ciudad está a rebosar con
semejante panorama no sería descabellado
pensar que acceder a una vivienda en
singapur puede ser todo un quebradero de
cabeza no os parece vamos seguro que
ocurre como en hong kong verdad pues no
lo cierto es que no
en 1960 el gobierno de singapur creó la
junta de desarrollo y vivienda el
housing and development board una
sociedad de vivienda pública que se
encarga de regular y gestionar el suelo
así como de construir y desarrollar
promociones inmobiliarias y es que en
singapur desde el año 1967 la inmensa
mayor parte del suelo es de titularidad
pública
[Música]
en ese mismo año de 1967 se aprobó la
llamada ley de adquisición de tierras
que facultó al gobierno para hacerse con
la propiedad de la tierra de esta forma
el suelo que se pone en el mercado para
la promoción inmobiliaria lo hace bajo
los criterios de la junta de viviendas
es decir en la comercialización del
suelo no opera el sistema de precios
es decir para que nos entendamos este
organismo público determina cuántas
viviendas va a construir ya qué precios
y bajo qué condiciones se van a
comercializar evidentemente siempre por
debajo de lo que sería un precio de
mercado
por otro lado también es esta misma
empresa esta junta de viviendas y
desarrollo la que saca suelo a subasta
para que las promotoras privadas puedan
construir promociones inmobiliarias
completamente privadas
[Música]
eso sí en todos los casos el suelo sigue
siendo de titularidad pública es decir
los propietarios de las viviendas no
pueden disponer de él por ejemplo no
pueden vender sus viviendas para
construir un hotel y la propiedad más
que una propiedad es una concesión
veréis me explico cuando un ciudadano de
singapur y recalco lo de ciudadano de
singapur porque los extranjeros no
pueden comprar una vivienda nueva de
promoción pública cuando un ciudadano se
hace con una de estas viviendas en
realidad no está adquiriendo la
propiedad del suelo ni tampoco la propia
vivienda en sí sino tan sólo un derecho
de estancia una cesión por un periodo de
tiempo de 99 años pasado ese periodo la
vivienda retorna al estado fijaos como
explica todo esto el primer ministro de
singapur después de 99 años el edificio
vuelve al estado el gobierno organiza el
terreno y construye nuevos pisos para
generaciones futuras esta es la única
manera de reciclar el terreno para
asegurar que todos puedan comprar un
apartamento de nueva construcción si el
gobierno deja de vender
sin limitaciones antes o después nos
quedaríamos sin territorio para
construir nuevos apartamentos li xiang
un primer ministro de singapur y ojo
porque en las promociones privadas este
plazo suele ser inferior
[Música]
eso sí durante ese periodo de tiempo
durante esos 99 años los propietarios
pueden hacer con las viviendas lo que
estimen oportuno si no quieren vivir ya
en ellas las pueden vender o las pueden
alquilar
[Música]
de hecho no es infrecuente que los
propietarios de viviendas más antiguas y
las cosas les van bien pues vendan o
alquilen estas viviendas públicas que se
caracterizan por ser muy austeras sobre
todo las antiguas para mudarse a
condominios a urbanizaciones a
promociones privadas que en el caso de
singapur pues se construyen con mayores
niveles de lujo pero amigos aquí no
terminan todas las peculiaridades de
este curioso sistema para nada
[Música]
dado que es un gobierno público el que
construye y vende la inmensa mayoría de
las viviendas el gobierno lo utiliza
como un instrumento de política social
bueno o mejor dicho de ingeniería social
por ejemplo para evitar que se formen
guetos y dado que la población de
singapur tiene una cierta diversidad
racial las viviendas de un edificio de
una promoción se adjudican de tal forma
que la proporción de propietarios tenga
una distribución étnica similar a la del
conjunto del país
es decir esta que veis es la
distribución de la población de singapur
por grupo étnico pues bien en cada
bloque de viviendas los propietarios se
reparten más o menos de la misma forma
que un bloque o una promoción tiene por
ejemplo 100 viviendas pues encontraremos
74 propietarios chinos 13 propietarios
malayos nueve propietarios indios
etcétera etcétera
sin embargo eso no es la cara mala de
todo esto tal vez lo peor es que el
gobierno utiliza la concesión de estas
viviendas para promover determinados
modelos de vida por ejemplo las parejas
tradicionales pueden acceder a la
propiedad con enorme libertad pero en
cambio las personas solteras o las
personas que quieran convivir con
personas de su mismo sexo o bueno
digamos que lo tiene mucho más
complicado
[Música]
sorprendido de que en un lugar
supuestamente tan capitalista podamos
encontrar semejantes niveles de
intervencionismo pues no deberíais ya os
hemos contado aquí en visual político en
alguna que otra ocasión como el modelo
político económico y social de singapur
es una especie de mix entre políticas
capitalistas del libre mercado y
políticas muy pero que muy paternalista
donde el estado promueve activamente
determinados modos de vida y castiga a
otros
[Música]
en este caso en el caso de la vivienda
no es sólo con la adjudicación también
por ejemplo con la otorgación de
hipotecas en condiciones muy ventajosas
para las personas se cumplan con los
criterios que impone el estado si no los
cumples pues mala suerte que quieres
vivir sólo de fastidias que quieres
vivir con un amigo te fastidias que
quieres vivir digamos con una pareja de
tu mismo sexo pues ya lo sabes te
fastidias majo
[Música]
ahora bien más allá de estas cuestiones
que a mí personalmente no me gustan nada
pero absolutamente nada lo cierto es que
este sistema ha tenido bastante éxito la
vivienda de promoción pública es mucho
más asequible en singapur que en otras
ciudades con un éxito comparable como
por ejemplo londres sydney o hong kong
en promedio los nuevos compradores
destinan menos de la cuarta parte de sus
ingresos a hacer frente a las hipotecas
pero un momento todo esto no es algo que
salga gratis
[Música]
el dilema de la factura económica
si por algo es conocido el gobierno de
singapur es por mantener a raya los
impuestos y el gasto público sin embargo
con todo este tema de la vivienda la
cosa cambia
el sistema es claramente deficitario la
junta de vivienda y desarrollo reporta
un déficit de 1.470 millones de dólares
en el último año fiscal por la menor
venta de pisos 1500 millones de dólares
es la diferencia entre lo que cuesta al
estado los trabajos de urbanización y
construcción y los ingresos por la venta
de las viviendas 1500 millones que son
financiados con cargo al presupuesto
público vamos que se financian con los
impuestos sin tener en cuenta la
propiedad del suelo este es el esfuerzo
anual que el gobierno de singapur
destina a la política de vivienda una
cantidad perfectamente asumible para una
economía del tamaño de la de singapur
ahora bien quiere decir esto que los
gobiernos de otros países deberían
hacerse con todo el suelo y encargarse
de la promoción de viviendas tal y como
hace el gobierno de singapur pues
yo creo que no
[Música]
y amigos el caso de singapur es muy
particular hablamos de una ciudad-estado
con un enorme éxito económico que se
gestiona casi como una empresa y donde
las limitaciones de suelo son más que
evidentes las diferencias por ejemplo
con países como españa o argentina
saltan a la vista y ni siquiera está
claro que en el caso de operar como un
mercado más libre realmente libré los
resultados fueran muy diferentes y todo
ello por no hablar del enorme poder que
este tipo de sistemas le otorgan a los
políticos para diseñar las sociedades a
su antojo
pero lo que sí ha conseguido singapur
con este modelo y creo que es algo
innegable ha sido desarrollar un
urbanismo y un esquema de precios
inmobiliarios que favorece el desarrollo
de otras muchas actividades de mayor
valor añadido por ejemplo gracias a que
los precios de las viviendas están
contenidos los ciudadanos de singapur
tienen mayor capacidad para ahorrar e
invertir por ejemplo invertir en nuevos
negocios en fin este es el particular
modelo de singapur un modelo más para el
debate así que llegados a este punto
turno para ti qué te parece el modelo de
vivienda de singapur como siempre
déjanos tu opinión en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle al botón de la equis suscríbete a
visual política una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]